it's so beautiful up here
good puppies not a lot of people here
i know it's nice i'm so excited because
i am planning to propose to shannon
today
so there's that i think about larry
what do you think he's doing well i had
a dream about him not to be like a full
la stalker but
it's just those eyes
i hope he gets to come home with us
we'll see
shannon is a destroyer of systems i
cannot
get anything by her if there's something
hidden she will figure it out
i am losing my mind this way
[Music]
ah look are you ready for your forever
home
hi hello i've coordinated all with matt
he wants to have larry with the ring on
his collar
and larry he needs this kind of home
where it's secure
and there's love in abundance
for him to be the engagement dog
i couldn't have asked for anything
better you see them ah
i see them over there okay let's sneak
up on them
i know you're a little bit nervous
you're going to your forever home
hello yes
[Music]
everything's approved i don't think i'd
see either a museum
i think i can officially hand over larry
the love dog
oh my gosh oh what beautiful friends
you're gonna have
oh we're all gonna
and there's some little gift on his
collar are you
angel so larry and i have both decided
that you are my
and his forever home
[Music]
so if i can see this
[Music]
shannon you are my best friend and the
most
compassionate brilliant amazing
wonderful person i've ever met
you are proof magic exists and i want to
spend the rest of my life with you
[Music]
will you marry me
[Music]
i love you so much thank you so much
this was
very impressive on a lot of levels
i could never have dreamed anything
like that like just just
surreal you nailed it perfect thank you
just something fur thank you so much
this is storybook ending it doesn't
happen all the time but if we can
accomplish something like that thanks
god
that is why we're here thank you so much
thank you so much for finding
your beautiful couple thank you for
taking him ready to go home larry go
show you your
home yeah oh it's our happily ever after
[Music]
larry
[Music]
you